[موسيقى]
يقع فوق افضل اماكن للغوص في شرم الشيخ
هذا الفندق الفاخر حياه ريجنسي فقد عاد
هذا المنتج عذو الخمس نجوم الى الحياه بعد
اربع سنوات مظلمه فخلال ذروه الربيع
العربي انخفض عدد الزوار الى اكثر من
النصف رغم التخفيضات
الكبيره
ولكن بدلا من الاستسلام يقوم المدير
التنفيذي مع المدير العام للفندق بتفقد
احدى الفلال
الاثنتين التابعه للفندق التي يتم انشاؤها
والسعر الاولي هو 3 ملايين دولار وقد تصل
الى 20 مليونا ورغم الفوضى على مدى
السنوات الاربع الماضيه يصمم المطورون على
ان يكونوا اكثر من مجرد وجهه على البحر
الاحمر تستهدف الشباب بل يريدون توفير
المزيد من الترفيه للحفاظ على عملائهم
لاطول
فتره وخارج بوابات الفندق توجد هذه القطعه
من الارض حيث يخطط الشركاء لانفاق نصف
مليار دولار لبناء مجمع تسوق
ترفيهي وعلى بعد 15 دقيقه في اخر الطريق
توجد ملامح منافسه كبيره على طريق النجاح
قد تصل مساحه هذه الارض الى 7 ملايين ونصف
المليون متر مربع وتقع على حافه جبل سيناء
على بعد ثلا كيلومترات من البحر
الاحمر ولكن البحر يقترب من المنتجع ليشكل
اكبر بحيره مياه مالحه تصل مساحتها الى
120 الف متر مربع وشواطئ تمتد لمسافه
3500 متر واما نائب رئيس شركه بروبرتيز
سيتي ستارز حسن شربتلي فلديه امال كبيره
في امكانيه شرم الشيخ ويقول ان مصر التي
بلغ عدد سياحها 15 مليونا قبل انتفاضه
2011 ينبغي ان تتنافس مع دول مثل تركيا
واسبانيا
وفرنسا ولهذا يقول مسؤولون تنفيذيون في
سيتي ستارز بانه لا يوجد ما يوقفهم وسوف
يبداون بفندق فيرمونت وملعب للجولف واما
فنادق رافل والفيلات فسوف تاتي في المرحله
الثانيه بالاضافه الى منطقه تسوق وبالطبع
كليوبترا ستكون جزءا من هذا المزيج ومع
العشرات من المنتجعات التي ما تزال في
مرحله التخطيط والانشاء ستكون مصر بحاجه
الى مزيد من
السياح